this was something i didn't know about
you that when you guys put together
jackass
you had an opportunity you had a choice
put it on mtv
or put it on saturday night live yes
that would have been unique and i'm
surprised you went with mtv
well it would have been great to be on
saturday night live it was a
a wonderful opportunity i appreciated
what a great opportunity it was
lorne michaels did he meet with you yeah
we we sat down at the beverly hills
hotel together and discussed
it i was going to get like three or five
minutes on the show every week to do
what i do
wow but at that point we
had we were making the pilot for jackass
and it was me
and all my friends and you know spike
jones and jeff tremaine
and i would have to leave that
to do saturday night live oh they didn't
want the whole crew they just wanted you
right to do stunts on film pranks or
stunts
no [ __ ] that would have been very novel
they've never done anything like that
yeah so i at the time in my ignorance
i once again i'm like i'm just gonna bet
on us
right but i respected what a great
opportunity it was i can't believe that
that's really unusual i mean i'm just
fascinated that saturday night live like
like the muppets came you know like the
first season
like all of a sudden they just want to
hand it over to you a three-minute
segment
yeah but i you know i wasn't going to
have complete control like
we did on jackass it was it was a smart
move
in hindsight it was it could have blown
up could have and then you might have
been kicking yourself in the head and
why didn't i go with saturday night live
and it's kind of weird like once you
turn them down like they
it's like the ship sailed or something
you know yeah yeah there's no going back
yeah which is weird i mean i don't know
why but
that to me is really nice there was no
need thank goodness yeah